[Music]
thank you everyone my name is Dominic
price I look after our storage database
and capacity products a Google cloud
platform I'm very excited today day 3
the conference which has been an
incredible conference to talk about how
Google has reinvented databases and how
those people come in to Google cloud
platform can learn from us and take
advantage of the things that we've
learned so let's start about talk about
the early days at Google people often
say that Google was late to cloud and
well Google got into the public cloud
space in 2014 Google has been running
one of the largest private cloud
infrastructures for almost 15 years
and so even though we've only been
working with our external GCP customers
for about four years we have 15 years of
learnings and technologies we've
developed over time that really have
made it possible for us to work with
these to be customers and enable things
that they haven't been able to do before
so the purpose of this talk is to take
you through Google's journey see if that
map's to some of the things that you're
seeing as customers and some of the
journeys you're going through and then
we'll talk to one of the customers that
has gone through this journey on GCP and
then we'll take a little time to do a
demo because all good talks have a demo
for those 15 years Google was internally
building technologies that met our use
cases and we were hitting use cases that
were a little bit different than the
rest of the world of seeing so we would
develop these technologies and we wanted
to push these technologies out to the
outside world but prior to Google cloud
platform the only way for us to do this
was via white papers and so we published
lots of white papers so if you go back
to 2002 we published the original Google
file system white paper so this was what
we had learned running a distributed
storage system that we could push back
to the rest of the world
we followed that with BigTable and we're
gonna talk a little bit about the
origins of BigTable in this talk and
then that spawned the no sequel movement
and a lot of the things that have
happened in the HBase space and in the
Hadoop space fast-forward a little bit
we published the spanner and f1 papers
in 2012 and then finally we got into the
Google cloud platform time so now we
were actually able to take these
technologies that we had developed and
that we'd offered back to the community
as white papers and offer them as actual
cloud services public cloud services so
bigquery is the same technology that was
in the Dremel white paper cloud BigTable
is the same technology that was in the
cloud BigTable white paper and then
cloud spanner is the the combination of
the technology that we talked about in
the spanner and f1 papers and so really
we've been able to take these 15 years
of experience and then leverage those as
we've gotten into the public cloud to
help customers build new and exciting
things so with that I'm very excited to
bring up Chris Taylor to the stage chris
is an early Googler he was one of the
original authors of spanner and as our
tech lead for all structured storage
products not only in Google cloud
platform but at Google in general
welcome Chris
so now I get to embarrass Chris so I
really want to start at the beginning
because one of the things that people
often ask us about is why why did Google
have to build its own technology so
first thing for Chris so why did Google
build zone database technologies instead
of using what was available well so I
think the thing Google has always had to
deal with in its history is scale a lot
of our applications have been internet
facing an internet search and they just
sort of scale with the size of the
internet and when you look at you know
the BigTable paper
it's full of URLs and signals and there
was really nothing we could pull off the
shelf for internet scale the and one of
the things that we learned is that as we
were doing BigTable and as we were going
through the use cases I think one of the
things we saw was that it ended being a
really good tool for using for building
other things at Google yeah you know you
started to started to see us branching
out a little bit into more things many
of them were facing the internet they
were Google customers and Google has a
lot of customers and so you know you you
find that BigTable is a good hammer to
use on all sorts of problems that you
come across and a good example of this
is sort of early in my personal history
when I joined Google I worked on a team
called Google Alerts and Google Alerts
you know sends you email when the web
search results change for a query of
your choice my first project at Google
was learning to run BigTable and the
reason I was learning to run dig table
was because we had a my sequel back-end
that was getting a little uncomfortable
at the number of users the number of
registered queries that we had and so I
did a pork cool and one of the things
you like to say to me is that in the
early days we're responsible for
indexing the internet and that doesn't
really fit in my sequel and so you know
that's a common problem that we had
that's correct yeah and for the back
we're having a little trouble with the
monitor screen so if you guys could
bring up the water screen that'd be
awesome thank you so okay that's kind of
the early days of BigTable so kind of
stepping forward you know it sounds like
you know in the
early days you know the quick we were
basically shipping binaries in
containers to the teams to run their own
BigTable you know and obviously today we
run very differently and a much more
centralized way so kind of how did
Google make that decision why did we
move to centralized services so how does
that work right so again going back to
Google Alerts when I first started with
BigTable the BigTable team was handing
me a container and I was meant to go run
it I was on a two-person team and I was
on call for a big table cell which was
entertaining I was sending mail to the
BigTable team every couple of weeks
because I needed learn about the command
line flags I needed to figure out how to
do upgrades and I was behind on my
upgrades let's be honest you're never
behind anything Chris so there were a
few things that BigTable saw in moving
to services here there's there's two
that earlier point saving a lot of
unnecessary specialization and toil and
there's a certain agility the BigTable
gets from controlling its own release
cycles being able to do upgrades for its
customers get to change more things than
we would expect this move to services
was a painful thing for us the the first
versions didn't work that well there was
a loss of control for the teams the
service didn't necessarily get
immediately better but this is something
that we iterated a lot on over time and
over a couple of years because BigTable
odds could see the customer experience
if we could change things quickly
BigTable got a ton better 100x
improvements in throughput huge progress
in tail light and C cost reductions
adding features when I came back to
BigTable in 2009 creating a table was a
trivial thing you could just show up
click get table and really not that far
off from the experience you got today in
public managed databases so overall the
move to services was a huge success for
Google it's very very rare for anyone at
Google to be running their own database
and really this experience making
BigTable into a service was such a
success that when we looked at an
offering like spanner that we built a
little bit later we designed that from
scratch to run as a service yeah as
we're going to we wanted to show a
little bit of historical
photos so the prior photo was actually
when the internal spanner service went
to GA you saw it Chris was the tall guy
in the back and then this was actually
one of the first outages so the team is
working with the customer who's the
smiling guy in the blue shirt who's
actually debugging the the problems with
the team so the pros and cons of
centralized services so we've talked a
little bit of a big table and some of
the things learned so why build spanner
and and I think the question that I
always get is you know why did we think
spanner was possible right cap theorem
all these other things so like why did
we think that this was something we
could do so I'd like to say it's that
we're visionaries of some kind but it's
not really very true instead we were
kind of dragged to the realization that
no sequel and eventual consistency
weren't working for all of the BigTable
customers Google changed a lot over this
period we were getting into things like
Gmail Google+ personalized search and
consistency was starting to really
matter to some of those things at the
same time googles sequel native ads and
payments businesses were growing in size
growing in sophistication they were
using my sequel and it was frankly
struggling to keep up we were sharding
it really heavily needing to rashard it
from time to time and then also we were
seeing this sort of steady drumbeat of
serious bugs even the occasional major
outage which were basically caused by
eventual consistency ambushing
developers and so sitting in the
BigTable team we were seeing
applications building consistency
transactions indexes and even sequel
engines as layers on top of BigTable and
we came to the realization that the hard
problems we were avoiding weren't gone
they were just pushed to customers and
so well spanner looked in its end state
looks big and ambitious it didn't sort
of spring fully formed out of someone's
head it was the next thing we could do
based on what we were seeing built
around us I would also say that spanner
was an inflection point for us in in
technical infrastructure at Google it it
was when we decided our job was to take
on as much storage complexity as we
could handle and this was really so that
Google's many many businesses could move
faster and do more the more we took on
the more they could not have to do and
we're really not done with this process
either one of the exciting things about
coming to work every day is that I can
see the impact that spanner has on
Google's business and I know there's
just more we can do and more that we're
working on cool this is actually with my
favorite photos so why don't you give
the background in this photo sure so
this this was early days in spanner
we had a big night lead test that ran on
40 or 50 machines we called it sis test
sort of randomized really stressful
thing we ran one copy of it a night at
that time and this was our board of
post-it notes to show how we were doing
so this this little arrow points to the
week we were on so that would have been
a Wednesday I was kind of a rolling list
thing so every day I would put up a
post-it it was an extra check if it was
next you can see little Mark's in pen
for what went wrong that day what a lot
of X's on there like we're chat
fortunately we've exited this phase of
our history and we now run significantly
more testing every night and it comes up
a lot greener but it was a was a fun
Spanish starts the same way everything
else does so as we talked about you know
we've been doing this for about 15 years
we've talked about BigTable and spanner
and so you know what are the things that
we've learned kind of running this
centralized service over the last 15
years that we think is you know that you
found surprising that you kind of keep
in the back ear pocket like when you
think about these problems sure so I
think the main thing that that I take
away is an appreciation for just how
hard it is to develop and scale a
managed database service you know you
don't I don't know if you can see my
hair I cut it short when I was getting
ready for this presentation there's a
lot more gray in it now than there is in
the picture you can see of me on the on
the board here we've documented your
your hair turning gray through yes so
it's been over a decade since the
BigTable paper a decade of developing
spanner but half a decade since the
paper and you know when you get into the
code you can see that while the 20,000
foot architecture is the same as what we
documented there almost all the code is
different there's a lot more of it
and we've learned a lot about why
simpler alternatives to what we do are
just catastrophic and this is really an
underrated benefit of using a high scale
service like span or a big table we've
found that the only way you can scale a
spanner or BigTable 10x and customers
bytes or QPS is to decrease outages per
customer by torque ups by 10x and
anything else in the number of failures
you have just grows and crushes you as
the service maintainer and that's the
treadmill we're on here in GCP databases
but if you're a customer you likely are
not scaling by 10x you probably aren't
even that big to begin with but you
really feel the 10 X availability and
reliability that had to go into the
service during that time and that's just
kind of math working in your favor
generalizing from it a little bit and
you know I mentioned this a little
earlier gules gained a lot of
flexibility and agility by pushing
complexity into its first party database
services and taking it out of
applications that leaves the service
very challenging to build but if you can
do the work and get it right that
amortizes really nicely across all of
your users yep you know it's it's been
really interesting you know obviously
you've seen this evolution but you know
Google with 500 engineers or a thousand
engineers is very different than 50
thousand and so running services for 50
thousand engineers is a very different
it's a very different scale problem yes
great and so you know now you've you and
I've been working together on kind of
this journey into the public cloud
plenty of bumps along the way and
disagreements and collaboration but of
the things that we've learned kind of
what do you think is what are these
learnings you think apply to what we're
now seeing with our GCP customers and
the journeys that we're seeing from our
GCP customers yeah I think learning is
that there's not much to this story that
is Google specific not every customer is
building a search engine that's that's
only a couple of companies but every
application has a database or storage
somewhere and the fundamentals of what
you want out of a database really don't
change
you'd rather someone else operate it you
want it fast
you want it reliable and you don't want
to spend your apps complexity budget on
limitations of your database platform we
also haven't talked much about security
but the list of requirements for that
gets longer every year and that's an
every customer all the time yeah
apparently there's a new thing called
GDP are the people are talking about
like that's new so we put years of work
into being good at that stuff right
these problems are really near and dear
and we work on them every day and we're
excited to bring some of those solutions
to Google cloud our our best work and
really this this harkens back to the why
did we build spanner stuff is when we
can study what our customers are trying
to do what they're building and see what
seems like the right thing to build
that's when we that's when we excel
cloud platforms a new era for us you
know we've been doing the private cloud
thing for a long time but we're excited
to work with all of our customers on you
know a system we think is really the
future of public cloud databases awesome
so Chris thank you so much for the
historical context let's give him a
round of applause thank you
great so that's about what Google has
learned and I think what's most helpful
for people is here is the journey that
other GCP customers have gone down so
I'm very excited to bring Daniel
Spoonhour aka spoons CTO of light step
to talk about their journey in the cloud
cool great I'm excited to be here and
talk about a little bit of what light
step does how we built it and how we use
some of the tools that Dominic and Chris
were just talking about right
that's me almost everybody does call me
spoons I feel like that's the first
question everyone asks I used to be a
Googler now I'm a light stepper and I
guess I like to build developer tools
that's kind of what I've been doing over
and over again in a bunch of and a bunch
of different places so I wanted to start
with Google paper also not one of the
papers that that these guys mentioned
this is a paper that one of my
co-founders wrote almost 10 years ago
now it was called dapper and it talked
about Google's distributed tracing
infrastructure so dapper was a
monitoring tool that was built at Google
to help Google engineers understand how
requests would flow through the system
that had been built each request would
hit potentially thousands of machines
thousands of services and all that data
was then being aggregated and flowed
back to the user and understanding where
it was slow could have been in any of
those services and this tool wasn't and
continues to be really critical in
building applications that are composed
from these many different services fast
forward a couple of years now it's not
just Google that's building these kinds
of systems and a lot of other folks have
started breaking their applications from
monolithic entities into smaller pieces
be they micro services service all kinds
of things like that but the point is
that once we've broken them up it's you
know it's easier to build the pieces
independently it's either easier to
deploy those pieces independently and
it's easier to scale them independently
and that sounds great right maybe if
you've done this you're gonna disagree
that everything's great or maybe if you
can guess from the picture that maybe
not everything's great does anyone know
on a Status page it's not a real Status
page it's like the Status page that you
wish your server your service providers
had
it was one of my favorite tweets we were
replaced our monolith with
micro-services so that every outage
could be like a murder mystery and the
thing is you know breaking up the
application was great in terms of being
able to build it but being able to
understand it especially understanding
it from an end users perspective just
got a lot harder what we've done is take
a story which had one sort of actor in a
sense and we've split that role into a
whole bunch of pieces and now if you
were to read any one of those roles it
wouldn't make any sense you really need
to see the big picture in the whole
story so how did deafer work well
roughly for every request for every
search for every RPC between services
gap or captured timing data it captured
logs and the connections between those
services this is a lot of data and if
your Google handling a bajillion
requests a second it's a lot a lot of
data and so Deborah's approach to this
problem was it's actually pretty simple
and effective
it was just throw out 99.9% of the data
or maybe even 99.99% of the data
immediately without even looking at it
that might sound a little bit crazy but
even with that tiny sliver of data
there's still a lot you can do so for
example Google runs analyses of the
samples it's taken to understand and
answer questions like on average what
was causing web search to be slow over
the last week was it query rewriting was
it image search results was it a
different type of damage of search
result or maybe it was this good old
network latency these are all important
questions in they're critical to
prioritizing engineering engineering
work and to improving performance
there's a tension though between
operating at this kind of scale and the
features that you might be able to offer
in other contexts so it lights that we
took a pretty different approach and I
want to talk about that from the
perspective of one of one or our
customers so lyft has deployed by step
and uses light step to understand their
application they've built using a
Microsoft service architecture and they
use this really cool mesh their service
mesh technology called envoy to
basically proxy requests between those
micro services and one of the things
that you can do with that that's pretty
awesome is that mint
we could integrate really quickly
between lift and light step and get kind
of instant visibility into how request
we're passing from the app all the way
through all their different micro
service systems so how does light step
differ from depper the short answer is
that light that looks at all of the data
so for lift that means we analyze more
than a hundred billion our pcs every day
that's something like tens of millions
of Microsoft micro service requests
every second and we think if you're a
lift engineer you're firefighting and
how did you want to understand what's
happening every single one of those
requests could potentially be important
to you and so we want to make sure that
we have all of that data there available
to you to answer those questions to do
this we had to take a pretty different
approach to what was done in dapper and
we had to put a lot of thought and
effort into building a really efficient
system for processing all of this data
this is part of our team we've taken
what we've learned from dapper what
we've learned from using and building
other kinds of monitoring tools and
we're trying to take all of that
experience and bring it to our mission
to help developers understand
application performance as they adopt
these modern architectures and platforms
I would love to talk about the work that
our team is doing and building these
high volume real-time event processing
systems but you have to come talk to me
later about that I want to take a minute
and talk about the parts of light step
that are not super high volume real-time
event processing systems we still need
to deploy services we still need to
store timing data trace data a lot of
other stuff persistently a whole bunch
of stuff that was critical but not
unique to our business and to our
product and as light step got off the
ground we had to make a lot of choices
where do we build where do we buy where
do we use open source where do we
reinvent the wheel or hopefully not so I
want to tell you a little story we're
monitoring service maybe you're
wondering what tools we use to monitor
our monitoring service and of course
there's a bunch of them light step is
one of those so we operate a bunch of
different instances of light stuff one
of those we call meta and metas job is
just to keep watch on the rest of light
stuff and at the time of this story meta
like the other instances included a
Cassander deployment that was used to
store some low
frequency information - mph frequency
time series data and we kept running
into problems with resource use some of
the instances were booming we had some
problems with the way that we had
deployed it on top of kubernetes which
maybe you can imagine where this is
going a little bit but roughly what that
all led to is some persistent and
reoccurring corruption in the underlying
SS tables and this in fact led to one of
the worst outages we've ever experienced
luckily it wasn't in a customer and
facing environment but it still felt
pretty bad to have one of our own
instances down for quite a while and a
lot of engineering time went into
mitigating the problem I think days of
Engineers time just to get us back where
it was working again and we were not out
of the woods by any means because a lot
of these configurations were also being
used in our other environments and they
just hadn't hit these problems yet so we
quickly did some evaluation to look at
some other options and we ended up with
spanner maybe not surprising in the
context of where we are today but it
actually I think took us less work to
migrate from where we were on to spanner
then it would have taken us to build the
expertise and just fix the deployments
that we had in production live at the
time I think it's really important to
look back at the choices we've made and
understand where what we could have done
done better but what we learned in this
case I think it really reinforced me for
me that you can't overestimate the
engineering hours that'll go into
understanding and maintaining a
distributed storage system again this is
all hindsight I feel like really obvious
but where we were you know we were just
making a lot of decisions really fast as
a small company but I think you know
this is one of the instances that I look
back on and whenever we have a choice to
use a hosted service this is the kind of
thing I think about because with
something like spanner I don't think
about the human operational costs and
I'm confident that we're in control that
we can scale it up as we need and we can
make choices about what other technology
we want to use to complement that so if
you kind of look under the hood it light
step today like this is sort of that in
a nutshell some secret sauce on the top
and then claude kubernetes cloud sequel
storage
and spanner those are kind of the
important parts of what we have the
monitoring tool our customers have
pretty high expectations for light steps
reliability they depend on us to be
there even when their own services are
not working so they can better
understand what's happening so as a
service we you know as part of our brand
to be a reliable go-to kind of place we
depend on other services to help fulfill
that promise and so I think to take
spanner as an example you know I feel
really good about being in multiple
regions now and knowing that even fairly
large failures in terms of you know a
snowstorm or something like that are not
going to affect the service that we
provide to our customers so to kind of
close up if you're adopting any of this
cool technology be it kubernetes micro
services cloud functions whatever it is
but you're having a little bit of a hard
time understanding what's happening
first you can go talk to some folks that
are right down at the end of the hall
the cloud native computing foundation
they are incubating open tracing helping
tracing is an open source API for
getting data out of an application into
a platform like light step they're also
incubating envoy and a bunch of other
really cool stuff and then secondly of
course I would be more than happy to
talk to folks about what we're doing at
light step I'm really excited about the
technology with building and the way
that we can really help push forward the
way that people are building these kinds
of applications so with that I wanted to
thank everyone for for listening I want
to thank Dominic and everyone at Google
for having me up here on stage thank you
so much yeah great
in these sessions I always find it's
it's the most helpful for GCP customers
is to hear the experience and learnings
from other GCP customers and so I really
appreciate spoons being here to do that
now we've talked a little bit about the
past we've talked about the present so
now we're going to talk a little bit
about the future I'm so I'm very excited
to bring up
Deepti and Steve from the cloud spanner
team and they're gonna take you through
a preview of some new things that are
coming in cloud spanner Dominic
hi everyone my name is leta Shrivastav
I am the product manager for cloud
spanner and I was just to give a quick
history
I was also responsible for launching
spanner internally that photos from my
phone that you saw earlier
so my noogler project with launching
spanner so I have some history in it and
I'm joined with by Steve middlecoff who
is a senior engineer in the spanner team
and he's going to show us a few cool
things that we have coming out so so I
talked about this in my talk yesterday
but basically as we heard from Chris and
Dominic you know we've been building
spanner for a long time and of course
the history of database is is 30 plus
years long so we could have added
features like there was a ton of
features that we could have added and
exposed to our cloud customers but we
really wanted to be deliberate about
what we offer on the cloud platform to
our customers based on what they're
looking for right so so we added
multi-region etc last year and then you
know there's a - really highly
anticipated features that I get asked
about a lot that we're here to show
today this is not a promise of timelines
or sort of announcements of the feature
launch it's more about what we've been
working on and what we hope to have in
the next few months we also launched
before we get into it we also launched
the import/export functionality for
cloud spanner which was the top feature
demand last week and we demoed it also
yesterday so but today I want to talk
about the things we're working on that
we think are super cool so what Steve
has here is our UI console if you aren't
familiar with spanner this is the the UI
that we have and we start with the
instance page on our UI cloud spanner
instances are like in other situations
clusters so basically this is our unit
of replication topology and instance and
isolation so you can have multiple
databases inside a cloud spanner
instance so in this case we're looking
at a DML demo database so yeah the first
function on Y we're going to talk about
is DML which is doing inserts updated
and deletes in sequel so just to be
clear you have the ability to mutate
data to insert update delete through the
API but we didn't have this DML
capability in sequel and now we are
working on releasing it soon so we're
excited to talk about that so in this
case our demo database is a ticket info
database and as you can see the schema
on the side it has a count event ticket
and all those kinds of tables fairly
standard relational database and we also
have two indexes on the event table
event by date and event by multi
different IDs so now let's actually
query the database now this is something
you can do today so you you can go to
the query console and you can actually
type in queries and you can get the
results right there so so Steve typed in
a query to get information for all the
events in the event table and as you can
see we have no multi event ID set in
this table so let's look at the explain
plan again something we have today where
you can look at the the sequel explained
as you can see it's using the index to
be efficient about about fetching this
data all right so now what if we wanted
to change the multi event ID to just a
cloud next for all events that happen as
of Tuesday which is when cloud next
started so so we have an update query
update where and voila we have a DML
query that completed so let's look at
the explain plan and as you can see in
our experience and now we have applied
mutations so we're supporting explain in
the and the DML case as well so let's
look at what we actually did so we're
not faking this out like the the data
should have changed its live demo
it should say multi event ID for all the
events that are as of tuesday and as you
can see I was lying we can actually make
DML statements work now the cool thing
about this is that you can do this for
petabytes guild databases or very very
small databases and you can do it right
in the query console but of course when
we release it we're going to have it in
our API in the you
and also through our JDBC drivers so
just again to be clear we do have a JDBC
driver right now which is read-only
because we didn't have DML statements
and when we launch we will have the JDBC
driver as well and we plan to have or
I'm support as we go along spring boot
hibernate excetera once once we have
this functionality so hopefully I
answered number two of the most
frequently asked feature requests now
let's look at a another feature that I'm
super excited about that were also
planning to launch soon this is called
the career statistics feature so we're
back at our instance page and as you can
see it's the same demo instance it has
the same ticket information as before
the same schema now if we enter the
instance in this case now we have a new
tab career stats and if you click into
the course tax tab you can see that
we're basically showing you all the
queries that took up the most resources
in the last in this case minute so we
have multiple buckets in which we
aggregate this information one minute 10
minute one hour 24 hours so hopefully it
gives you a good view of how things are
behaving over that period of time but
we're most interested in the last minute
for right now so this is sorted by the
top 10 queries by CPU but if we let's
click into the first one so now we have
an info pane panel there that shows us
more information about this particular
query that's been taking the most CPU in
the last one minute so it's been taking
261 CPU seconds and as you can see in
our info panel there is there's more
information like average latency rose
scanned rose scent etc so in this case
you can see that the Rose scanned and
the Rose sent are the same which means
that the query isn't doing any
aggregations or filters or joins and if
you look at the query text which is
right there you know so you can actually
inspect that particular query as well
you can see that it's not doing any of
those things so you know the intuition
is is accurate here one thing to talk
about here is
the queries using a parameterised values
so it's using bind parameters and this
is actually a useful thing to do in
general both because it helps you with
performance and latency because the the
query engine can then have an
opportunity to cache this query plan so
that you don't have to rebuild the query
plan every time you end the query and if
you saw the statistics earlier the query
has actually run about 150,000 time last
minute but it didn't have to rebuild the
whole query plan each time even though
the account ID value could be different
so it will obviously help it perform
better but also it helps with collecting
these kinds of stats right because the
engine understands that this is the same
query that you're running over and over
and over again so now let's look at a
another query that's that's more
interesting so this query took 34 CPU
seconds and so much less than the
previous one and it ran only a thousand
times but in this case the row scan and
sent are different and you know
obviously that means it's doing
something more interesting with fetching
the data and then returning it to the
user so look we have the query opened
right there so we can take a look and
what it's doing is it's fetching all the
venues sorry the seating capacity for
all the venues and Steve is moving
faster than I can talk but but in case
you wanted to debug the query as it was
running it either development or
production you would want to open it and
run it and see what it does right so you
can click on a button right there in
that query stats page that'll open this
sequel API query API and you can
actually inspect the query that you can
run it as the ran and you can see that
you know we have Beijing Stadium
category 1 and category 2 both have
6,000 seats and if we look at the query
explained plan because you know we want
to see well what is it doing why is it
doing it you know you can see that it's
applying all these filters and doing
across apply not a hash tag of your join
so the idea here is that you know as
you're both developing your system and
as you're looking at your system in its
performance you can inspect right there
what the thing is doing you know this is
a plan for this particular invocation of
the query but it can give you an idea of
you know let's say it's taking a long
time and you want to see what is it
using the right index or not or do I
need to create an index all those kinds
of things you can see by by quick
inspection so these are some of the many
features we're working on if you have
feedback for us you know I'll be here as
well after the talk to take your
feedback and answer your questions but
hopefully this was as exciting for you
as it's been for us so thank you so much
for listening thanks thank you
Deepti and Steve I'm so excited to get
this out I know developers have been
asking for this for many months and so I
look forward to when they camp this in
their hands now one of the things that I
wanted to do because we have been
talking about all of our databases is
give you a quick recap of all the things
that we've been announcing here at cloud
next over the last three days so first
of all a cloud firestorm so we announced
this a while ago in firebase so as part
of the firebase console so now
cloud firestorm is available to you with
the UI embedded into the Google cloud
platform cloud console it introduces
data store mode so what this means is
customers that are using data store can
now use the same API with no changes and
take advantages of the new features that
are in cloud fire store and so what this
means is that now all data store
customers will be automatically migrated
over the next you know period of time
with no code changes no interruption of
service so that all those data store
customers can take advantage of all the
new features that are in cloud fire
store so we're very excited about this
second of all as we've been migrating
all of these large enterprise customers
so we talked about target earlier we've
previously talked about HSBC and Home
Depot as these enterprise workloads are
coming over there's lots of existing
applications that require things like s
AP and Oracle so you talked a lot about
our relationship with s AP and all the
things that we're doing to provide an
amazing experience for our SP customers
on GCP and now we can bring those oracle
workloads to GCP via our partners
specifically Accenture and some of the
other strategic partners that will be
bringing announcing the service with
cloud BigTable so one of the biggest ask
for cloud BigTable was the ability to
replicate the data so this had been
previously in beta and it is now
launched to general availability with
the new improvements for the SLA
unavailability that comes along with
that cloud spanner we recently announced
import/export which is now available to
everyone and then throughout the rest of
year we'll be launching the DML
readwrite JDBC drivers and query
statistics that Steve and Deepti I just
showed us and to make sure that we
talked about all of our products on make
sure everyone understands the the
portfolio and the breadth of products
that we offer offer our customers so
Cloud memory store is our in-memory
managed Redis offering so if you have
redness workloads that you'd like to
bring to Google cloud platform and have
us manage for you we're very excited
that this is in beta this is another
hotly requested feature from our
developers cloud datastore fire store so
that beta goes out so if you have
document database workloads especially
if you're developing web or mobile
applications this is an amazing product
that we're very excited to get more
tightly integrated into the GCP
experience cloud BigTable for our low
latency scalable wide column stores
there's a number of talks about cloud
BigTable but if you have those HBase
workloads or some of the Cassandra
workloads that we'll talk about in my
database migration talk that is
available for people to provide that
workload cloud sequel so managed my
sequel and Postgres so we introduced
Postgres a little while ago and now
that's in general availability again
incredible demand and people asking for
managed posters so now that that's there
we're very excited to see all the
applications that people are going to
build with that and then cloud spanner
so our scale out mission-critical our
DBMS that we just talked about really
provides a portfolio of first party
services now there's lots of other
amazing solutions that are out there so
we're very excited with our partnerships
and so Redis Labs is running a managed
Redis offering on top the platform mount
to be with MongoDB Atlas we have a
wonderful elasticsearch service through
our partner at elastic and we have per
second sequel server images that you can
run on GCE and then we just talked about
our SP and Oracle offerings so depending
on what you happen to be running on
premise whatever that might be or
wherever you're running your current
workloads
we have a set of offerings either
through Google cloud platform or through
our partners to meet those needs and
with that thank you very much I
appreciate your time today please enjoy
the rest of the conference and feel free
to come find us after the session thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]